actually what I think is so funny about
this is
like a lot of the skills which studies
say are particularly female so like
empathy listening skills
um that kind of thing are so relevant in
recruitment it blows my mind sometimes
that
you know we wouldn't have more women
recruitment but I do understand why I
mean I I definitely will do everything
that I can to inspire more women I'm
just about to in the next couple of
weeks sit down with cross-section of
women from our business to understand
really what their challenges are try and
understand different people's
perspectives my mind is only my journey
and what I felt but I think having
people in women in senior roles I think
listening evolving being being you know
understanding the pressures definitely
being parents and I think the men and
women actually with that kind of thing
making sure that you have got a setup
which is feasible when I came into
recruitment it definitely was like you
this is not a long-term career because I
can't see anyone who's got kids no no
Role Models exactly and when I in 2019
when I push in really hard about that
and that was because I had met my
husband by then and I knew I would want
children in the coming years and I was
like I'm not letting this derail my
career I'm going to do something myself
to make sure I've got a setup where I
can have everything that kind of I want
to do in life as well and I think I
would say to women like it is such an
amazing industry it is it's so much fun
and you know just
but but speak up take responsibility
like make yourself heard the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
VIN cherry
at the award-winning Source breaker